Kate where did your contact with Todd  begin and what was his pitch to you he  sent me the script and there was no  contact at all and I think it's it  speaks to him wanting to get an actor's  response to things he didn't want to  send a cover letter he doesn't want to  tell me anything about it and um and so  the conversation when we began to speak  about it it was intensely practical  because there was so much to do it  wasn't until we actually got on set and  started to to  um to deconstruct the scenes that we got  to the sort of the metaphysical layers  or in rehearsal we we did all of the  sort of the backstory stuff and I think  that comes from him being an actor is he  wants he doesn't  um you know I then gradually of course  had so many questions uh for him during  the process of the of the preparation  but he tended to the practical